maybe
maybe he doesn't like the eddy matchup
with jack that that's interesting
anyways i feel like i feel like claudio
is a really good option against eddie he
has a lot of tools that can that can
kind of deal with eddie's
options especially when in relax so like
we'll see before something picks them up
that does uh all ford four by itself the
hop kick has enough range to pick him up
too oh gosh okay
yeah so if he tries to do an attack that
transitions into relax and then has a
follow-up the hopkin could clean launch
him
all right here we go and that back one
is just gonna harass
uh eddie here we go the follow-up he's
gonna get the wall here down two three
no he goes for the back two three three
oh no wow
for that one you have to hop kick pop
and go for the wall standing too it's
gonna be a weird range
whatever what oh he was ready to hop
with that
dude he goes for the hockey that time
but a nice whip punish here
from calum
first round start from both of them
right
yeah this was very scrambly
back and forth here especially by the
wall they had a weird sidewall situation
for both players
oh there's no punish
that's that's not safe you gotta be able
to push that down four four
yep
let's see what he does
waiting for this opening this
opportunity he's still relying on that
back one is his offense starter
got to watch out for that back dash
though that back dash is killer
and he's starting to notice maybe that
he's not breaking throws yeah that's
definitely looks like one of the biggest
weaknesses we've seen out of calm so far
which is scary of course because you
know
because of the natural movement and the
back dashing it it can be hard to kind
of throw this type of betty so he's
gonna have to be very careful as he
makes his approach all right running two
here what's the mix
the power crush
sounds like the right drive came out too
the gate slammed on that one that was
crazy
i mean he always has blue stuff if you
think about it
oh yeah
the potential for blue stuff it's just a
different kind of blue stuff
again with the background this time try
to fish
see what callum does here
oh he went straight to relax but again
that was able to deal with it oh god i'm
looking yeah you all go up here
hit my relax once i'll go right back
into it
sidewall's done
good adjustment here goes to the low
relax three to four
oh he's gonna have to deal with this
huge life deficit here but i'm calum i'm
back dashing
nice
the impatience there netted a counter
hit and the round
right now one round away from taking
that first match we're at the bottom of
the floor
no more walls
devils pit one of the few stages with
transitions
right
up there there's a few but it goes to
bigger areas
like uh
this human building oh yeah that's right
yeah
got him
nice
second hit not ready for it
let's see what he does
that was so so good though so good from
calum
oh one more he could do it oh not for
you
lefty two alive no side roll uh you can
side roll that right always you can i
think it's uh
oh it's against the petrol is it left
it's one of the i think it's left
terrible it's
yeah
pretty
50 50. you guess
but yeah it's not guaranteed but he does
have the other screw from it
which is guaranteed
down four twos from calum have really
been one of the big
uh factors in this matchup so far onyx
holy moly to close it out
oh you got the pickup
jumping three that's not even the jack
move what was that
forward three i don't even know
whatever it was it wasn't the right call
and calum gets the first game because of
it
uh unfortunate for sure
yeah very unfortunate but still able to
make things work out and uh gotta go
back to the drawing board i mean it went
down to the final round there could have
gone either way
but again it's unfortunate you gotta
really uh i guess come on top of those
scrambles and for the most part calum
really really really came out on top uh
defensively i think the play style kind
of
beats out what onyx was doing and onyx
is obviously still struggling to find a
way to get in at least with claudio he
never really found a way to kind of get
in most of the damage that he got uh was
from from whip punishes right it wasn't
really from pressure so
if if i'm him if he's gonna play that
cell you might as well use jack that way
at least you have things like the
jackhammer that could deal with certain
things you have an all-purpose slow
that'll be a little bit better to use so
i don't know
maybe maybe he's afraid of the back
that's just getting out of that range
could be you know i do actually agree
is he switching that's the question
oh what do you think yes you're the
master you think he is
he's switching yeah i'll be devil's
advocate no he's not he's sticking it
out with claudio
110 thousand
and fifty
percent oh [ __ ] you got audio yeah you
got it
kinder gym
and he picked kindergarten specifically
for the matchup
i wonder what it is kindergarten must
have a hidden secret we do not know
about
um
no windows part of japan and no windows
[Music]
oh boots boom
the low
oh no
i think he should have won a jack
dude countered down for two all day oh
he wasn't ready for that last hit yeah
man
that's unfortunate that's just again
you're showing like
when when he got they start slugging it
out when there's those scrambles you
gotta really make sure you come out on
top right now callum is just proving to
be the the better brawler
you're not even going for the extension
like i mean you got to test your
opponent sometimes
because what's the threat the way onyx
is playing there is no threat everything
is mid high
not even getting an opportunity to like
kind of open up his opponent
and that low is not gonna do enough he's
gonna have to like do do things like
that
there you go follow up
he has the wall positioning now but
that's a great block
you got lucky there
yeah i'm really sorry for cal just to
hit the brakes on that combo too oh
he's just outside of rage
he's gonna have to watch out for the
rage drive that one
yeah that one
that one that one hurt ouch
round three again here we go two rounds
straight calum looking to advance
onyx if he loses here he's gonna be out
see what he does no double relax
that's really tricky honestly
sidewall saves lives
but look at the life deficit may be too
much callum could just kind of run here
but he's still he's still fighting yeah
oh that was a whiplash
pressure's been working for him
uh but opportunity for onyx last chance
to be honest tournament life on the line
here one hit'll do it
he's still alive
he is still breathing honest
candy bring it all the way back
good timing there
no punish he's gonna have to be careful
he's gonna have to do something here
this time go for the knee
the mid
the pickup
[Music]
hope for the wall a little bit short of
the carry the throw works out though
yeah he wearing him down finally got the
throw
what's he gonna do here he's gonna have
to watch out oh my gosh that could have
been a wall splat if he went to the
floor
onyx looking really good here
do something
no
orbital oh my god so close don't get hit
by ray drive
follow him
he's dead
ah brother unfortunate but hey callum
moving on onyx now out of the tournament
a valiant effort nonetheless
[Music]
valiant effort indeed
but regardless as you mentioned onyx out
here and you